Ce que je trouve intéressant,
c'est que la cause palestinienne,
elle est extrêmement structurante.
Et moi j'observe aussi ça en tant que palestinienne,
c'est-à-dire que la
question palestinienne
vient 1 peu de challenger nos sociétés
sur justement nos libertés,
sur nos libertes, nos libertés d'expression.
Et là, je.
J'ai besoin de ressituer ce qui se passe en France,
dans ce qui se passe dans tant d'autres pays,
je sais, je fais référence à l'Allemagne, mais aussi euh,
aux États-Unis.
Je crois que vraiment, la question palestinienne,
elle est structurante en ce sens,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle vient quand-même
prendre la température,
où est-ce qu'on en est sur notre liberté d'expression,
sur euh, notre
liberté de pouvoir en la se mobiliser sur 1 cause
qui est extrêmement chargée,
euh, sur laquelle on a tant de choses à dire,
parce que y a 75 ans de passif,
mais y a aussi des mémoires qui sont très chargées,
y a la mémoire de la choix
pour la population juive,
et puis y a la mémoire aussi palestinienne,
qui derrière elle,
euh, fait référence quand-même à la mémoire coloniale.
Et je crois que toutes ces temps de
de crise patient,
qu'il y a dans nos sociétés, notamment occidentale, euh,
sont liés à ça,
sont liés à des deuils aussi, qu'on a pas fait
à des pansements,
à des, à des plaies, qu'on a pas pensé,
que ça soit sur la mémoire de la choix,
mais aussi les les mémoires colonial,
et c'est aussi ce qui vient
Cristaliser la question palestinienne,
parce que c'est au fond aussi 1 des mémoires qui se
qui se, c'est les morts et les vivants de
de mémoire qui qui doivent parler,
qui se regardent aujourd'hui d'une certaine manière.
Donc moi, je. Je veux dire que c'est extrêmement
intéressant de regarder à quel point le ce sujet vient
en fait de challenger quand-même nos sociétés
sur ce qui est acquis
et ce qu'il faut,
c'est sur quoi il faut continuer à se battre,
à savoir là en l'occurrence,
c'est liberté fondamentale.
Et le 2e point que je veux dire, c'est que moi, ce qui me,
me, me, me, me,
me me choque le plus,
c'est effectivement l'incapacité de la justice
à aujourd'hui et de des et de de l'état à à être 1,
1 rempart effectivement sur euh,
la protection de ses libertés,
parce que je veux rappeler que
pour beaucoup de cas, ce ne sont pas des autos,
euh y a, y a, y a,
y a 1 y a 1 éducation qui est abusive
de cette procédure,
y a parfois des articles 40,
y a parfois des préfectices, tout à fait,
mais en dehors,
y a aussi, comme le disait Vanessa kodexio,
ni des organisations, ni des individus exactement,
mais là, ça,
ce que je veux dire, c'est que je ne comprends pas,
euh là, je.
Je fais référence à mon cas et celui de gameurice,
étant d'autre,
hum, où nous sommes convoqués, euh.
Suite à des plaintes qui sont.
Déposées par des organisation
qui sont clairement encore 1 fois
identifiées comme étant, euh.
Proche du régime israélien,
ou qui valide en tout cas la propagande du régime
israélien. Je ne comprends pas pourquoi là, notre machine,
la machine judiciaire, ne fait pas barrage en disant,
mais il n'y a pas matière à poursuivre guillaumeuris,
qui est 1 humoriste qui a le droit
de se moquer de nathania rou,
des personnes qui sont candidates, euh.
À des élections, ou des individus,
effectivement, des citoyens ordinaires. Ouais,
et c'est là où moi ça m'inquiète,
c'est-à-dire, c'est. C'est cette capacité à certaines
organizations à, à,
à prendre, vraiment à se séduire de ces procédures
et. Hum. Et que c'est 1 impact très concret sur, euh.
Nos vies, nos libertés